- She called one night and said she wanted
to go trick or treating in
Georgetown in Washington D.C.
And she had the whole outfit,
she said, from herself and for me.
- [Woman Offscreen] That
she'd made herself, right--
- Of course.
Well, I don't think so. (laughs)
- [Woman Offscreen] No, you
don't think she made it herself?
- Because it was a sort
of sheet with a head
- [Man Offscreen] It was a silk bag.
- [Woman Offscreen] There's a photograph,
you've gotta see this
photograph, in the book.
Yeah, it's like a silk hat.
- Yeah.
And so we went around,
all around Georgetown.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman Offscreen] There
were are. There's it.
- [Smith] I had to speak
because she has a very well known,
very good voice.
- She did?
Jackie had a distinctive voice?
- Very distinct.
(audience laughing)
And so we had to watch that.
She couldn't--
- [Woman Offscreen] So you
must've been the one that
had to say trick or treat.
- So, I had to say trick or treat.
(laughs)
And, nobody got it.